un calor sofocante atraviesa arizona y
marca la rutina de sus habitantes me
detengo periódicamente a lo largo del
día para asegurarme de que estoy
conservando la energía y manteniendo mi
temperatura moderada solo tienes que
estar atento a los signos de
deshidratación es sobrecalentamiento iré
en texas los lugareños salen a
refrescarse
oh hombre se siente agradable y
relajante para entrar en el agua fresca
este calor es una locura he visto a
mucha gente desmayarse con este calor
esta voz decir pero una práctica que
parece tan efectiva como natural podría
ser nociva para la salud ellos creen que
los enfríe lo que la gente no se da
cuenta es que realmente se suda incluso
en la piscina así que si la percepción
es que estás más fresco pero la realidad
es que probablemente no les des la
oficina del servicio meteorológico
nacional de houston advirtió sobre
temperaturas máximas de entre 40 y 43
grados celsius e instan a permanecer en
el interior evitar actividades
extenuantes y mantenerse hidratado
el potencial de calor extremo continuará
esencialmente hasta principios de
septiembre porque las cosas tienden a
seguir secándose y el golfo de méjico
tiende a seguir calentándose
a principios de esta semana varios
lugares del sur registraron temperaturas
diarias récord como wichita falls en
texas donde el martes se registró una
máxima de 46 grados las olas de calor en
el hemisferio occidental que han
afectado también a europa causando
devastadores incendios pueden ser
avivadas por el cambio climático según
los expertos